[Music]
I've spent a lot of time in the last
year or two talking about what I think
is wrong with the left because I'm a
liberal and I want the left to be
liberal again and now we have Trump
which brings this whole other set of
problems and people say to me well
you're not attacking him enough and it's
like well we now have this x-factor and
everything is kind of upside down right
now and I guess it's incumbent on people
like us to pave the way for other people
because they're they're waiting right
well I mean let's get to Trump for a
second because because to me you started
out with talking about ideologies mm-hmm
this is a different thing entirely first
of all I always say if you could have
had a crystal ball during the campaign
and you could have shown who the
nominees for various official positions
would have been Trump doesn't get
elected no matter who he runs against
and I don't think he gets elected if
he's running against even Joe Biden who
I considered to be you know kind of a
zero
I think Biden runs away with it um I
think he's a manifestation of our
dissatisfaction with the political
system which we are I mean I don't know
anybody who's satisfied right arm and at
the same time it's not necessarily going
to take us away from our problems
because our problems are too much power
in the presidency not enough attention
paid to the Constitution and the fact
that we've gotten away from the various
things that make America great which is
things like the separation of powers
checks and balances but the tendency of
Americans is to blame things on for
example the last administration or
something we this is 50 years of trends
building on top of trends this is not a
new thing and every president in my
lifetime has taken us farther down the
road to what presidential stories
Lessing are called the imperial
presidency well now it's the hyper
imperial presidency we have a congress
that reminds you of the Roman Senate
yeah at the end where we're you know if
you say what is the real skill level
that you possess as a senator its
fundraising my Lawrence Lessig the the
Harvard Law Professor had said that you
know he diagrammed how you work your way
up through the political system down and
the first thing they ask you when you
want to be a small-town mayor so
we're but have a little do a little are
by your name if how good are you are
fundraising yeah so by the time you
actually achieve a higher office what
was the number one qualification they
were looking for the whole way
throughout you were a good legislator
none of those things so these people I
had a grandmother who is this amazing
fundraiser to raise funds for charity
should go to these events and you that's
what these people are good at yeah so it
should surprise us very little when you
say okay we a check-and-balance here and
they're not there they're only there now
they'll be there if their contributors
wanted to be there or if they can make
political hay but in terms of me you
watch watch the Republicans now in
Congress and it's if it wasn't so
serious it's fun to watch because these
people are some of the the most astute
hedgers you've ever seen in your life
but they don't know how to edge now on
this one they're sitting there at a fork
in the road going do I cast my lot with
the Trump administration it's going to
be a big star and a hero in ten years in
which case I turned the right turn at
Albuquerque
and it worked out right or is he going
to be seen as a disaster at anyone who
was aligned with him is you know a
nightmare so do I need to take they
don't know what to do and all they want
to do is figure out the way where
they're going to turn out the best so
they get reelected or whatever down the
road I mean all of these people are so
concerned about a job that they should
only do temporarily anyway that it's
warped their entire ability to have
anything connected what we would call
leadership today yeah you you've hit on
so many things that I talk about all the
time on the show about separation of
powers and an imperial a shammy right
and why we should be governed by the
Constitution and not just by the whims
of current events and things like that
so the imperial presidency I think is a
really interesting thing because I've
been on the record for years when when
george w bush was doing all the
executive actions i was against them
when obama was doing the mows against
them i'm against them now now we have a
guy who's obviously willing to govern
fully an authoritarian yeah yes who's
willing to govern by them but it's like
it's not only his fault it's not his
fault for grabbing the power that his
own buddy was going to to him somebody
was going to do it somebody was going so
is that the best argument for limited
government then that forget what your
politics are on specific issues that
these people that want money and want
reelection Xand
that are okay to be a third retained the
only fight against them is to rein in
the power they have over us let's talk
about that permit because that's another
one of those terms or select we were
talking about at the beginning with
liberal and conservative all these
things that that are hard to define a
real meeting what is limit who has a
limited government in the world finally
what what country in the world has well
that the functioning is really not a
limited government whereas that because
the truth is is we have a country here
that has 300 million people we have a
budget that is enormous yeah we have
needs that are incredible um how could
you have a limited government a limited
i would argue limited meaning that it
should just do less it should have a
little less control over us meaning that
it should take less from us so lower
taxes as a general thing we could
probably scale back the military a
little bit we could probably scale back
some social services and they might be
taken over a little bore by private
enterprise that sort of thing
i don't mean that we should dismantle
the government and not you know what i
was right but the problem is is that you
end up if you take away if you go and
you started to remove things you would
find out i think it's a belief so
because we don't do this so it's all
theoretical right yeah all right but the
belief is is that if you took away this
stuff you would find out why it appeared
in the first place now does that mean
it's going to come back in a form that
is bloated and because we all understand
that the government has built-in
budgetary increases every year which is
again you would say part of the problem
this is where zero balance budgeting and
all that stuff comes into play but the
real wake-up call for americans um and
it's funny because if if i could do
anything if you wanted to say i'm going
to cut the defense budget by 2/3 and i'm
going to give every American a travel
budget where they can go around the
world and begin to see how other
countries work because the the biggest
nightmare for Americans in terms of
upsetting all your beliefs is to go to
some of these other countries and be
shocked that it works you go to
Scandinavia now Scandinavia would not
work here because the entire system is
dependent upon you being Scandinavia
right it's basically a homogeneous oh
well I had a Scandinavian girlfriend and
we we were getting on the freeway here
in Los Angeles and as you know getting
on the freeway Lopez there's a struggle
yeah I mean you know you have and she
looked at me and she said this is what's
wrong with America she goes in Sweden
it would be left hand would go like here
we go left hand will go and I said
that's what's wrong with you people I
said that's why you can't compete like
we can because we fight for everything
right I've been even getting on the
freeway as a struggle but when you go
there what's shocking to an American is
that they have a system that would not
work here but it works there and they
don't tell you when you're growing up
these things and you have to actually
see it yeah now what that means is you
come back here and you say okay
government is not necessarily we're kind
of taught sometimes the government is
necessarily inefficient and and can't
work and I always say that that's a
defeatist attitude back when the
clinton-gore White House was brand-new
they had a program that they called had
a great name great marketers like the
reinventing government and the idea was
that this is not necessarily the way
government has to be right could we
improve it could we make it better what
I'm always suggesting is we really
haven't tried and remember it's a big
bureaucracy even if you decide you want
to go in and change it it's hard to
change I mean I think when you're going
to find out what Trump is he's going to
find out pretty darn soon that the
bureaucracy has a lot of ability to push
back right so when I talk limited
government for me it's about dismantling
some of that bureaucracy so that
potentially we could maybe get to some
of that clinton-gore stuff for me when I
look at the system the one thing that we
could do that would affect the lives of
average Americans released in terms of
cutting big government is change the
foreign policy because when you look at
discretionary spending as we all know
many of the things like Medicare and
that's not this Grusha Social Security
doesn't not discretionary spending the
military though is um and remember that
if people actually look at a 1960 budget
for the US military and a budget now
it's totally apples and oranges yeah
because of the way they deliberately
hidden things so the 1960 budget for
example the Veterans Affairs costs are
all built into the defense budget now
it's a separate part of the budget so
when you'll hear somebody say well we
don't spend that much on defense now
well deliberately apples and oranges
like so much of the budget same thing
with a with unemployment numbers and you
can't compare the the ones in the old
days to now because we exclude people
that haven't been looking for work right
okay so when you look at the amount of
money we spend and you say that's free
money that's money you could allocate
elsewhere right so when you talk
cutting government what would happen if
you cut the defense budget in half I
think we're still the largest military
spending country in the world by the way
I should point out that we have a
Department of Defense and yet Americans
have not fought on American soil
my mother's 80 years old she was - the
last time Americans fought on American
soil
what has that money buying us so when
you talk about well-spent funds if there
are a lot of waste and fraud and
Medicare II darn right there is yeah but
through the government pipeline people
are being helped on the other end who is
being helped by the defense budget right
when I bring this up I'm called an
isolationist which is a term that goes
back to the 90s all sorts of baggage on
purpose all I want is a government with
a foreign policy like every other
government in the world how can that by
definition be isolationist how many
bases outside of Russia does Russia have
which is probably the next most
intervention I didn't count them on one
hand okay we have in excess of 125 maybe
we'll fuse to be 180 and you pay for
that as a taxpayer right what do you get
for that right well is this where Trump
actually made headway with things
because he would say well why do we have
bases in Japan he's forgetting the
forgetting the moral center that we may
not be sure about but if you're just the
average person because he basically made
the argument you're making
why isn't Japan paying us to protect
them so he's making the sort of same
argument that you're laying out there
right maybe not as both on our own but
it's a good point and the reason he made
it though is the reason that every
president you could think of makes the
argument and that is that the United
States public has been and always is
except in the most extreme situations of
a mind that they don't want that and and
when you go look at how this started
between 1945 and 1952 is when the
country made a huge change in foreign
policy and we've never looked back they
knew you could read the the Truman
administration and the things they knew
that the people didn't want this because
it's natural they say why am i spending
money for this better the other thing um
that's why george w bush ran for a more
humble foreign policy that's why
President Woodrow Wilson and Franklin
both won elections before they took us
into World Wars on promises to keep you
out of world wars
there's no president that runs for the
United States top job and says if you
elect me we're going to be in more
foreign countries it doesn't happen
because the electorate doesn't want that
and yet that's what we get so what what
does that say them because if you think
about it when Obama ran the first time
one of the reasons he beat Hillary in
the primary was because he was harder on
getting out of Iraq immediately that was
one of the reasons he was able to get
through the primary to beat her yet at
the same time I think he's the only
president we've ever had that in his
entire eight years we were at war we've
been in Afghanistan for this entire
eight years we're still there we don't
even know I mean I don't think anyone
has any clue why we're there anymore
i'ma give you to define war because I
all right now I was going to say I don't
think we've not been at war since 1947
probably since the Truman Doctrine but
it depends on what you mean I mean is it
war if you're funding war somewhere else
or is it only war if your people are
actually fighting and dying because
we've been funding war you know and
understand there's a whole rationales
called military canes II ISM that and
you can go back and read the documents
at the time they're very open about it
you know we have the Great Depression
and they tried all kinds of things to
get us out of that we were still in it
when the gin up 1942 the Second World
War started and you go look at the
production numbers and the economic
numbers and the graph is almost straight
up right so then in 1943 when it's clear
that the war will be over in a couple of
years a de tourny looks like an arm
wrestling match and it's too far go they
start thinking okay well what happens
when we turn off the spigot right
because I had a great-uncle who had a
small little rubber plant in Orange
County before the war when the war
started the government gave him a huge
amount of money to buy up all the land
you know we need all the way into all of
it right and then after the war they
simply said do whatever you want with it
so he sold it and made a fortune just on
selling the land but that's the spigot
right that's the text so there was this
feeling that we could go right back to
the Great Depression if you didn't keep
the spigot on ready this unnatural
amount of cash coming from taxpayers to
military to build stuff that we might
not even need but it keeps jobs going
that's
if I told you that we could get out of
all these countries in the world would
be fine you might say that sounds great
but if I said yes but we could also lose
250,000 jobs to people in the defense it
then you have to say right is it but
then one must ask are these real jobs or
are these jobs where you know Dave
Reubens tax dollars is basically
transferred to a guy who works in the
defense I mean right and is that really
capitalism in a we we go after the
socialist countries for being socialist
how different is it military Keynesian
is a kind of a social right we're right
we're just transferring it in a
gathering and then when we don't want to
stop this is where you know it's a bit
of a shell game because if we were
really concerned with defense you would
not give your best equipment to other
people right you would not say this is
our new m1 Abrams tank and we have it
but then when you give it to other
people what does that mean that means
they have the same stuff you do which
means you've got to go build better
stuff well it becomes a say a make-work
program if you will so how much of it is
just that that maybe this thing has
grown so big talking about budgets and
military and all that that raining it
back in would almost be impossible short
of something completely radical like I
would probably be four I'd have to think
it out a little bit further to know some
economists on it I would probably be for
like a 20 percent cut across the entire
board for the government just to just
cut every department back 20 percent
mostly because of the bloat and the
bureaucracy because I think you could
easily get 20 percent out of almost
everything but do you think it's
possible that we maybe gotten too big
that somehow turning it back could have
repercussions that we can't even imagine
well first of all start with when you
have a corrupt political system take for
example the question of tanks we just
brought up tanks well there's a famous
story happen at all six months a year
ago where it was a bit of a scandal
because the government doesn't want
anymore 10 military does not want
anymore tanks we have lots of them but
they build tanks and important districts
that have senators who then go and argue
that you know decimate my local economy
if we weren't building so they're
building more tanks than the military
says they want because we have to keep
the work see the military also smart
they locate and I love the US military
by the way I'm a military history I am
but but they locate the various
important
in places where there are powerful
politicians and what happened so you
have a real reason if you talk about
cutting defense you're going to have for
example congressman down in Southern
California who have marine bases that
depends on that money that feed families
that go into the local economies but
again do you have a Defense Department
to that is that what you and and if
you've got rid of that does that mean
you will suffer or does that mean you
know the true believers in capitalism
would say okay then we will reallocate
all that right if you believe that and
there are moral driving since it's an
ideology but but those funds will be
relocating to more productive measures
will be form of creative destruction if
you will um I think that's that's a more
logical question like if you talk about
cutting the defense budget for example
by 20% the problem with that is you
haven't cut the mission if your job is
to be the global policeman of the world
we're not spending enough now so you
have to match the funding well I would
argue that the problems yes and as I
think you have your match the funding to
the mission right if our job is to
defend the United States of America we
are wildly spending too much money right
okay so so here's the thing that never
gets debated it's like the dog that
didn't bark and Sherlock Holmes but the
subject we never debate is allowing the
American people a voice in the foreign
policy because if the American people
are allowed to decide the foreign policy
we don't have this foreign policy and
everybody knows it that's why we don't
have no vision that so that's why we and
it's the one thing you know you want to
say one thing about President Trump he's
probably kept more campaign promises
than any president I can think of
whether you want those promises or not
but the one he's pivoting on is a
foreign policy problems so the foreign
policy promise basically people thought
he was going to be more of an
isolationist and now don't use that term
not to slur that playing right into it
well that he's he was not he didn't run
on war let's put it that way
he said we're wasting a lot of much more
power more like other countries for
employment right which I get to be a
more hyper intervention right so an
American lens it comes out as if you're
an isolationist but just take care you
didn't worry about the hyper
interventionist country and yeah but you
suspect that he's actually shifting on
that the powers and I don't think he's
doing it because he lied I think you get
in there
don't the inertia that that that that
gets on you I mean for example the
Russian thing is fun to watch I mean
because there's no reason for us to be
at odds with Russian they'll say it's
completely ruins this is it okay what
we're going to depend these leaders now
have to be Nighy the bad guy I think
he's a good guy
but that doesn't mean you get into a
nuclear war over some miscalculation I
mean listen you have international
competitors but that's life and if your
job is as our military on you know we
have a you how do you explain we have a
policy and they updated all the time a
giant sort of global policy our plans
for the next ten years twenty years and
our main goal these policies say is to
have no international military
competitors none if that's your foreign
policy goals you're leading to
confrontation I mean that ends in
confrontation and it requires an
enormous amount of spending because our
old goal used to be to be able to fight
two wars on opposite sides of the planet
at the same time who else has a
preference so right the argument I read
Charles Krauthammer annoyed dislike
intensely um the other day he said what
makes America great is global leadership
in other words I guess we weren't great
before 1945 but but when you think like
that then you know it's not freedom it's
not liberty it's not the Constitution
it's that we are the policemen of the
world and we're the big dog and once we
lose that we're no longer great how the
heck did we ever survive up until the
Second World War
[Music]
you